there is one skill which can have a
significant impact on your professional
career in corporate and in Professional
Services and this is telling stories
with data this is exactly what we're
going to talk about in today's video I
will start first with sharing some
theoretical foundations on the topic
second I will show how this applies to
real life examples and third I will
share practical tips on how you can
implement the learnings in PowerPoint
big thanks to things that will support
firm learning by sponsoring this video
more about things said in a moment
they're crucial to it for everyone
working in Professional Services I want
to start by highlighting that the
ability to tell stories with data
matters and there are countless book on
this very topic describing all the
techniques and also advantages of doing
just that and in this picture you see
this stylized overview what this is all
about you might start with data and then
it's your task as a professional to cut
through this complexity to sort the
information to arrange the information
at some point also to present it
visually but then of course also to
explain a story and as you can see in
this picture it is only once you have
told a story that it really sticks that
people really can buy into it and one
Insight I want to share with you here is
that often people distinguish three
different levels of insights three
levels of insights that you can achieve
with your analyzes it starts with facts
so facts are raw data points unordered
information facts right so you have a
big Excel spreadsheet with lots of
numbers these are the facts and then
most of us are able to
consolidate the facts into some type of
summary right being an organized
condensed restatement of the facts but
the error that especially more
unexperienced professional to do is that
they stop here they send a summary to
someone and then more or less leave it
to that person to understand and figure
out what exactly this is supposed to
mean and so the third level of insight
that is missing here but is absolutely
crucial for professional communication
is the synthesis what does the summary
really mean what are the implications of
what you are sharing there's an
interesting scholar in this area called
Brent dikes who has a distinction that
he makes he distinguishes data telling
from data storytelling and if we match
this together data telling would be more
about the summary right you're just
repeating the facts whereas the center
this is the storytelling explaining how
certain facts fit into your
recommendation into an overarching
narrative so from all of this we can
conclude that successful storytelling
with data relies on a set of factors
data visualization narrative and an
understanding of the audience only if
you have a good understanding of your
audience can you really succeed in these
topics so for the remainder of the video
I want to discuss these principles based
on some tangible examples some of them
were provided by you from the community
so thanks to everyone who contributed
something let me start with this chart
which was sent to me this is an overview
of how the global market share for web
browsers changed over time trust me
first of all notice that this is not the
nicest way of visualizing the data right
it's a super intuitive to understand and
of course you also all can see that the
access labels are just absolutely
unreadable so let's try together to
think about how we can improve it and
also how we can change such a slide to
really share a narrative share a story
which is hardly the case here and so I
loaded all of this into the PowerPoint
plug-in thinks it and one of the
functionalities that is provided here is
that we are quickly able to change the
chart type so such an overview I'd
likely not choose these hundred percent
column charts are probably more like a
line shot so this might be the first
thing we want to do now we can see a new
visualization of the data which I
personally find already Superior in many
ways to what we've seen a second ago now
I cleaned up the chart a bit I toned
down the colors I included a chart title
if you don't know what that is I talked
about it else where it's a simple
element that talks about what it
actually is that you're looking at but
now the main question I like to ask you
is well what you actually want to say
here right so what is your story what is
your narrative and this is exactly what
you should think about if we are talking
about storytelling with data and when
maybe it is the great success story of
the Chrome web browser that we clearly
see here in the numbers if this is what
you want to talk about make sure that
you adjust the visualization accordingly
so in this example I now bolded the line
of chrome you can see that I added a
different color to it I added the logo
to it really make it stand out to focus
on this narrative in the data
visualization and also notice how I
added an action title your title element
on top of the slide focusing on this
very very narrative so if you don't know
what action titles are I will link above
another video of me talking in detail
about action titles a very important
chart element indeed the word of this is
actually not the main narrative that you
want to portion you're rather presenting
maybe in front of a group of Apple users
I want to highlight the current position
of the zafari web browser where then
let's change the chart accordingly of
course you now want to rather frame the
message around zafari maybe you want to
talk about how Apple managed to defend
the 20 market share of safari despite
the dominance of chrome so let's
highlight the fiery browser a bit more
let's maybe also add a logo and now we
can use think cell to support this also
in the chart let's bold the lion of
safari and let's also add a little bit
more distinct color to focus on just
that hope you agree that now this new
narrative is much more present pops much
more and of course it's quite different
from what we talked about a moment ago
with chrome being the dominant browser
all of the charts are created for
today's video were created with the
PowerPoint plug-in thing say and think
cell is also sponsoring today's video
I'm extremely excited about that because
I personally absolutely love things that
I use it almost every day myself the
statistics are absolutely insane nine of
the top 10 business schools use things
say this includes Harvard Stanford also
inside the school where I completed my
MBA in addition all 10 of the top 10
Global consulting firms are actively
using things say this includes firms
such as Boston Consulting Group so
learning think cell is a great time
investment because likely what ever Your
Role is going forward you will need to
make use of the tool so why not start
learning it right now personally I first
learned about it as a university student
so if you are currently studying in
business and Engineering in data science
Mass physics or any other data driven
discipline I can recommend you to use
think cell to just communicate the
results of your analyzes to tell stories
with data the right way and it is my
pleasure to announce that think cell has
launched a new program for everyone in
Academia so if you are currently a
student or if you are currently a
professor or if you are a PhD student or
any other person working in an academic
institution think cell extends the
things a license to you for free for the
duration of your studies so this is of
interest to you check out the link in
the video description to access things
for free in the new academics program
but of course if you are a professional
also negotiated a special deal for you
and this is that you get access to an
extended 60-day free trial to think sale
this is far longer than the regular
trial you can get access to that with
the link in the video description as
well there are no credit cards required
to sign up no other hidden costs check
out these things they'll offer it will
be very much worth your time let's look
at a second slide example first of all
thanks to the person delivering this and
here I want to talk a little bit more
about the narrative and how you can
support that with strong slides as well
so this is your slide talking about
expansion also from a business School
academic context and here notice how
there are two parts to the slide to some
extent right so there's an analysis how
this company grew in the past it talks
about internal needs it talks about
external opportunities and then here
also a chart talk talking about the
expansion showing how the numbers
changed over time so when I look at a
slide like this to me this seems like a
collage so let's try to improve a slide
like this and let's maybe focus a bit
more on this data part so let's start by
a strong action title highlighting the
strong growth that we found here and
also highlighting what the share of
Acquisitions was that maybe plays a role
let's include here in a simple bar chart
these chart types work for a lot of
different things that we want to show
until now I just copied over the data
that I found in this very text table
that we saw on the prior slide so this
is what we have here right a chart now
you can see also here that the numbers
are quite long with lots of digits but
this level of detail is often not needed
for analysis like this so let's rather
round this to millions and to do this we
can leverage things sale as well we
cannot divide the numbers by a certain
factor to give us the result that we
want now of course we want to look at
proper formatting and also colors as
well so we'll use the very same coloring
Technique we saw earlier but now let's
think of the narrative let's think about
what we actually want to show here what
is the point that we want to stress and
maybe this is about the very significant
growth that this company experience here
and so think so does offer different
ways for you to make it easy to include
messages like this so one thing we might
want to include here is a difference
Arrow so an arrow indicating now the
growth of this company let's maybe only
focus on the organic growth and if I
select this it directly calculates the
right number that we want to include
here and this is now of course a number
we can also pick up in the chart title
now you have here a column available to
the right where you can focus on the
implication so what does all of this
mean you make sure that your really
focusing on implications and not just
some random points which are not really
connected to each other at all let's
start with this slide example which I
want to use to highlight some topics
relevant to data visualization now I
want to work together with you to
improve this very slide I want to
especially focus on the chart creation
so you're on the different diagrams here
in limited so let's start by making it
all left aligned indeed and now let's
start by including a diagram here the
first one on the left this is where
things say can come in quite handy here
in the things and menu you can choose a
chart type that you want to use let's
copy in the data that we have seen a
moment ago and let's add a proper Legend
to these items as well now to make
everything properly aligned you can
actually also left align the labels now
with things that you can also use the
legend to choose the colors I would
always recommend you to choose rather
toned down Colors Let's now also include
an element to highlight the Millennials
color maybe such a shading here so let's
compare this to how it looked earlier I
hope you agreed that this already looks
much cleaner much more professional so
let's Now work on this medium chart so
here the one thing that is definitely
quite disturbing is that you they're
talking about two very different things
the generations and then something like
income brackets Without Really
explaining this and maybe include
something like boxes like this to just
explain what the two categories are all
about and now we can think about the
right chart type to add and then it
might look something like this for color
coding I suggest to use tone down colors
and distinguish the positive from the
negatives and now we can of course
include here some nice shades as well
these are the segments you would
consider most relevant for this smart
mirror project of yours let's now talk
about the third chart type here to the
right so this collection of bar charts
so let's include here again a bar chart
and no now aggregate the numbers based
on the generational split that we have
been using throughout the presentation
so far so the Boomers Gen X Millennials
gen that something that likely will
stick more with your audience than just
collecting lots of facts in the
potentially also not stressing the right
information points that we've seen in
this very chart now I'd love to learn
from you do you have any tips on how to
tell stories with data let us know in
the comments trust we can all learn from
that also big thanks again to think so
for sponsoring this video if you are
involved in Academia either as a student
or staff member with the link in the
video description you can get access to
thingsale for free three with the brand
new things sell academics program if you
are professional with the link you will
get an extended free trial which I
negotiated for you here in the community
if you already worked with things that
in the past let me know in the comments
as well if you took any value out of
this video at all please like And
subscribe to the channel big thanks to
all the members of the channel as well
thanks for your support my name is
Heinrich I release weekly videos here on
the channel so see you again next week
all the best to you